so this talk is about diagnostic reports
and nodejs it's going to cover some of
the material that gireesh covered
yesterday but it's also going to talk a
little bit about all I'm going to talk
about give you an introduction say a few
things that you can do with diagnostic
reports how to use them
basics and I'm going to talk about some
tooling a belt to help you use them so
my name is Chris Hillier I come from
Portland Oregon I'm known as bone skull
on the internet so I work for IBM
primarily working on nodejs related
things I'm a maintainer of MOCA which is
a testing framework also involved as a
maintainer of MOCA in the open J's
foundation cross project Council and I
am bone skull on get up and on Twitter
if you have nothing better to do you can
look at my tweets and that's bone skull
with a zero so I want to start with with
kind of some hypothetical problems so
you have a hypothetical problem your
process crashed so what happens in a
process crash is if you're lucky you're
going to get a stack trace somewhere
unless things went really self but so
you might get a stack trace and you've
been you're a developer and you've been
tasked with investigating the stack
trace and trying to figure out what's
going on so remember this is a this is a
dead process maybe your stack raises in
your logs and so you look at the stack
trace this says oh well you're doing
something weird and the stack trace
points to to this code where you're
you're saying like Rinder and you want
to delete a temp directory or something
any pass of this flag and so the error
that you get looks like this so error
not empty directory not empty or under
yadda yadda yadda not empty so okay why
would this fail some of you may have 90
so you're you're passing the correct
flag you're meticulous integration test
pass
works on your machine works in CI builds
green but this happens so one way to
help you figure out this problem is to
use the diagnostic report and can you
even see that anyway it says use a
diagnostic report and so let me describe
the diagnostic report and this is the
gist
it's a experimental module some
functionality added it's a node 12 so
this is in LTS you can use it but it is
an experimental API so that means it's
behind a flag you need to pass a flag to
use it
experimental if you're not familiar in
the node sense that that essentially
means the API or the the behavior could
break outside of the normal major
release cadence so if you do start using
them please be aware that they could
break that being said they do their job
very well but that that API might change
the output might change slightly you
know before we hit the next next major
so essentially what what this is is it's
a huge JSON dump reflecting the state of
the process most of I seen of them I've
seen work out to be 28 25k you can
trigger it several different ways
including you can give it some command
line flags you can create
programmatically you can even tell it to
dump a diagnostic report when you
receive a user signal so how do we want
to create a port in this case where
we've got this process that's crashed so
we're gonna we're gonna start up that
process again except when you give a
deist like so experimental report you
need that to do any of this stuff right
now you're gonna say report uncut
exception and then give it a nice file
name you don't need to pass the the file
name but in our case that will be
helpful but
normally it'll create this very long
filename based on the time stamp so you
run this in in your production and time
time passes and now you have another
problem so now you have a diagnostic
report and it crashed and now you have a
lot of JSON and so it looks kind of like
this where it's just like this blob and
you know we can kind of zoom in and
maybe take a closer look so it contains
a whole lot of stuff and I'm gonna try
to run through this pretty quick but so
there's nine or eight depending nine
top-level properties and the first one
is going to be header and that's going
to talk all about the the report itself
information about the node process the
command line you can see the version the
versions of the in the libraries that
node uses operating system version CPUs
all sorts of stuff so that's going to be
in the header next one if we will scroll
down and this is an order so the next
one you see is JavaScript stack and it's
going to of course give you the stack in
this case it crashed on an error
next you'll get the native stack which
is which is pretty far under the hood
and you may or may not need that but
it's there anyway the next will be
information about heap so this is your
your memory usage resource usage will be
your CPU usage a little bit about file
system activity next is this libuv might
need a better name but it's it's
essentially the state of the event loop
what's in that event loop right now and
so this is it you know it gets a little
technical but there's stuff in this this
particular event loop and over there
environment variables this has been
trimmed but it's everything in your
environment
Windows users will not get this so user
limits
if you're a user on a Linux system
you'll have like limits of what you can
consume shared objects will be the
shared libraries that that node has is
using and so what we are concerned with
like what can help us solve the problem
we have well it would be here in the
header so we look in this header and we
see we want to focus on this the node.js
version so the problem here is rim ref
with that recursive flag didn't land
till 12.10 so your node version is too
old but a struct
stack trace wouldn't tell you that so
great hey you found the problem good job
so you take this and you want to say oh
look this is this is the problem
everybody is you're going to slack and
you take this big report you paste it in
there and now you have another problem
and what you did was you just leaked the
entire environment like in the slack or
wherever you sent it maybe you sent up
through email hopefully you didn't put
it on paste bin but yeah there could be
your your your AWS stuff in there who
knows so your team lead is pissed and so
that's that's kind of what we need to
avoid so so how we gonna what are we
going to do about this if you want to
send one of these report files around
you need to make sure they're kind of
scrubbed of things that shouldn't get
out and so what you do is you go back
and you you delete your slack message
and you go and you open the report and
you you delete this secrets and then
figure out how to exit them and then of
course this is all very tedious so there
is a tool that I was working on and and
it's out now but it's called report
toolkit and it's a tool for processing
and analyzing diagnose reports it's kind
of a multi-tool so it does several
different things it's not Unix you know
you know how multi tools kind of suck to
do any of those with anyway so they
don't do any one thing great but
I'm getting ahead of myself so this
thing is go this does some cool stuff it
gives you a CLI tool to to consume these
things and there's programmable API you
can check out the docs which are
incredible
and there's the repo up there so what
can we do so we can use report toolkit
and give it this redact command and pass
it be the report dot JSON file or food
digest or whatever I called it and what
this command will do was is it will look
for things that it knows are potentially
naughty and need to be kept secret and
it's based on the black list that maybe
WS s get secrets project news you may be
familiar with that but you can kind of
customize it to your needs so what I
will do is it'll it'll replace all those
terrible secrets in that report file
with this string and so it'll and it'll
overwrite the file in place so you know
nobody's the wiser right and so now you
can you can safely pass this report
around sure with your colleagues you
know discuss it over dinner but so time
passes and you get you have another
problem so you have this this process
and maybe it's even a test or something
but you have this process and it's
running but but you thought it should
have stopped so it's not a zombie
process but I'm just gonna call it a
zombie process so you don't know why and
this is this is weird because so you got
this process and you'll know why and so
you open up your debugger and it doesn't
you know it doesn't stop it's not doing
anything it's just sitting there so it's
not hitting lines of code you know you
set breakpoints whatever so you don't
know why one thing you can do this is
something that report diagnostic reports
can help you with so you can actually
generate a diagnostic report on demanded
the process doesn't have to crash for
you to get a diagnostic report and so I
know we love command line flags and so
we can send report on the signal and so
by default what this will do is the
process will respond to the user to
signal and that that's configurable but
it but so you'll start start your
process and you can do this sort of
thing and with the process ID and so
that sends the user to signal and when
the process receives that signal nibble
say ah it's time for me to create a
diagnostic report and so it'll dump a
diagnostic report up so you look at this
diagnose report and then the I'm going
to cheat because I know where to look
here so I would look in this libuv
property and I would go down and look oh
look there's this timer and so this
timer and it's active so it's so it's in
the event loop and it's referenced so
okay it's so it's still on hasn't been
garbage collected fires an MS from now
nine nine nine that's a while right and
so you can see that using this you can
get a clue ah so I must have created
some set timeout or some interval or
something and you know I was off by
several orders of magnitude you know who
knows but that'll give you a clue to try
to figure out oh this is this is one of
the this is where a problem could be so
report toolkit if you aren't if you
don't know where to look so it can do
this sort of thing for you and so it has
this inspect sub command and this is
this is the thing I think is really neat
so there are these rules they're
heuristics they're just an algorithms of
functions that that accept a a report
file and you can examine the function
examines the report file and it decides
what to do and so the the there are
built-in rules one of these happens to
be the long timeout rule which will look
for this very situation in your report
file and so you
could run this on your port file any
report file really and it'll look and
you'll see is there anything fishy going
on here so one of those rules is it a
long time out one where it will it will
let you know if there's a timeout that's
that's far off in the future and it's
still active and so you could you know
write your own rules to this it's like a
you know a plugin system and so you
could you could write your own it works
similarly the swirler i came and say
that word but that's how it works
it works like yes lint wood and so you
can write your own rules published ESM
you could have it talk to the blockchain
it's not sure why you do that but you
could do that and so this is what the
output would look like so pretty simple
so it's just like this kind of tabular
setting where it says oh there's an
error very issue in this report file in
the rule that was triggers is this one
and then there's the thing with this bad
expiration date or time so that's one of
the rules there's there's others that
will look and make sure that you're you
know memory usage is within expected
range your CPU usage is within an
expected range there's another one that
actually will examine your shared shared
libraries versus the libraries that node
was built built with and if there's a
mismatch there and so that's not gonna
you know be something that most people
wouldn't be concerned about but if
you're compiling node that might come up
where you say have a different version
of open SSL than node expects so another
problem you might have so you got this
flaky process in the flaky process you
know it's running and you're not sure
why it just kind of it fails once in a
while you know maybe it fails on one
machine but not the other and you can't
really tell what the difference is so
one thing that report toolkit can help
us here is it provides a diff sub come
and so it's you know you could take a
report a Jason for BJ's and give it to
your favorite dipping tool but that's
for dipping source code or text files
it's it's not for dipping these report
files a neat thing about when we know
the data we have we can create a custom
a purpose-built diff tool for this and
so that's what this is it it tries to
ignore stuff that it thinks you probably
won't care about and so tries to kind of
you know signal to noise ratio tries to
make it nicer for you to to look at to
reports and say oh well that's how
they're different instead of this you
know huge unified dumper side-by-side
diff and and so it answers your process
how does this if you run this again and
again again you can you can dip them all
and say how does the process change over
time maybe that's a single process maybe
that's a process on several different
machines but you can dip any two reports
this way and the diff output looks
something like that
in this case we see that you know the
command line flags are a little
different so with this first report file
we actually said - II for for eval and
so the the Commandant was sent was
actually hey just write a report the
other one who knows but it didn't have
any command line options the the first
report was generated with 12.1 the
second one was generated with 11.2 and
so it this is this is an excerpt of that
diff but yeah that's kind of the idea
there and you know if you don't like the
the tabular kind of output you can
choose different formats maybe you want
to in JSON or CSV or something
another thing is maybe you got maybe got
processes that are crashing somewhere
maybe a lot of them and maybe you're
like
it's not not a big deal we can just
restart them because it's no right but
so you want to know how frequently
certain exceptions are happening and
maybe this will help you prioritize bug
fixes or who knows what um but to be
able to figure this out how often does a
particular exception happen you need to
be able to count them so how do you
count an exception well you need to
somehow you know you could you can take
the whole exception and stuff it who
knows but you could take a what you can
do here is you can take a hash of that
exception and you can kind of there's
there's some customization that can
happen here but you can take a hash and
actually just kind of output this a
little a little bit of JSON with an SH
one here music report toolkit of course
you could do that with a script report
toolkit we'll do it out of the box it'll
also convert these diagnostic reports to
CSV JSON even filter stuff so if you
only want a couple of those fields give
to filter table of course is that kind
of output you saw before newline would
be something like new line delimited
JSON if you need that sort of thing a
numeric I kind of let this kind of
experiment where you can like use it in
in a shell context where you can
actually pipe it to something and maybe
generate there's like these like neat
little tools that'll generate like
graphs and your console you could do
that and just combine it with filter and
only pick out you know a certain a
certain field and keep running that over
time redact of course is it's
essentially the same thing as the redact
command so you can combine these
transforms you write your own option npn
you know you can't do that but so this
is what if something would look like so
you'd get this stack hash and you can
see there is no such a one hash
calculated for this
I think you know you need to be able to
customize this a bit maybe if your
exceptions have some user information in
them and you want to get rid of that you
know maybe there's some personal
personally identifiable information in
there you should be able to pass it a a
like a red regular expression or just a
function and you know write your own and
plug it into this thing and it'll help
you generate those stack that that hash
and then you can give this to your
logging tool or your metric system or
what have you
so I think that's about it but what we
learned is what a diagnostic report is
how to create them it's not everywhere
you can create them but that's that's a
couple of them you can also create them
programmatically which might be useful
if you're trying to grab them in like a
server less environment how you can use
them to solve certain problems they're
especially useful of course in
postmortem debugging where you don't
have the option of running a debugger
because your process is stopped so and
of course how report toolkit can help
you work with diagnostic reports when
they become tedious or how it can help
you uncover problems that you may not be
aware of and so if you want more
information about diagnostic reports of
course it is in the lovely nodejs
documentation there's a tutorial written
by gireesh who spoke about diagnosed
reports yesterday and also he was the
one who got this code into core but
there's a tutorial there which links to
those two developer.com you can also and
I apologize this is not very legible but
the documentation site for report
toolkit is IBM github do for its lush
report toolkit and I'll leave that up
for a second but it is an IBM project
I'm the only person working on it but
it's
my bean project and so again I am
Christopher Hiller you can call me Chris
I work for IBM
I like node mocha and stuff look at my
website and things so thank you Montreal
and no Jess
[Applause]